greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about digital marketing course
so buckle up and let's get started
and so in today's world everywhere you
go it's all about digital so today it's
lecture is gonna be about all the
different marketing channels available
piece them together put together a
little digital marketing course for you
so first off before we get started I
want to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing that a company does a person
does an individual a group an
organization and they do it in the form
of an electronic device or with the aid
of the internet so that's really what
digital marketing is it's just having
something digitally not something
tangible like a billboard or newspaper
or TV and with that there are lots of
places where you can apply digital
marketing and so electronic devices we
think of mobile devices and so you can
certainly use mobile as a form of
digital marketing in order to help you
with your marketing efforts digitally
okay you can create apps you can run
advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience via different devices
like whatsapp and messaging okay
there's also search engines search
engines is where a lot of people get
their information from at least start to
do the research to get information you
have social media lots of different
social media platforms all the way from
you know tweeting to blogging to a
social sharing to social content okay so
a lot of platforms under the bucket
social media
you also have traditional forms of
digital marketing like email you can use
different email platforms to send out
email so lots of different ways
to communicate your product your service
your message to a large number of people
that are really targeted to your efforts
how is digital marketing useful well we
know provides different metrics why do
we know it provides different metrics
because it's all digital okay so anytime
you send out an email or post something
on Facebook you're going to get data
back when you get data back you could
take that data to determine how well
that posed or that email performed and
if it didn't perform up to expectation
you can make changes to improve
performance that's called optimization
okay so that's the great thing about
digital marketing it's useful in that we
get data in some cases instantaneously
and we're able to make changes in order
to optimize that campaign we can also
you know provide personalized user
experience so meaning if we know who our
target audiences on say Twitter or
LinkedIn or Facebook we can really cater
our messaging to that group probably
most importantly is that digital
marketing compared to traditional forms
of marketing and allow us to really
reach a global audience very easily very
easily at a very low cost that's the key
so if I want to target people in India
or Nepal or Pakistan I can certainly do
that and I can do that with the snap of
a campaign and I get data back and based
on the data I can tailor that experience
even better really just allows us to
really hone in on a particular audience
anywhere in the world very quickly so
these are just three of the main reasons
why digital marketing is useful some
other experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a cost
effective alternative to traditional
marketing so you know for those that are
familiar with purchasing advertise on
say TV or radio you have to pick a spot
you have to pick a program and
pick a timeslot associated with that
program so somebody's watching a program
and and that program tends to draw in a
specific target audience then you want
to show your ad around the time and that
program is slotted to air on TV because
you know you're likely going to reach
your audience however to purchase that
timeslot could be competitive and could
be very costly where there are forms of
advertising and paying for advertising
digitally and those forms are cost per
click or cost per impression and so
using a cost per click or cost per
impression model allows you to wheelie
go head to head and kind of an auction
style format where you can control how
much you pay and potentially get that
prime spot in front of your target
audience so it really does become cost
effective and it allows you to make
small investments to get a really
substantial return on ROI so let's just
say your cost per click is only 10 cents
but you're selling a product for 10
dollars well all you need is one click
in one sale to generate a very
substantial return on investment and so
knowing that you get metrics back on a
campaign you could slowly or quickly
optimize that campaign towards a very
positive ROI then another use for
digital marketing just enables targeting
users based on their actions and
preferences so again we can really hone
in on who we want to target it really
depends on the platform but if you take
Google ads for example and you want to
target the Display Network well we know
we have demographics we know we have
topics we know we have interest
we know we have retarget audiences in
segments audiences we have age we have
gender so you have a lot of options
available to choose from to really hone
in on who you want to target and we
talked about remarketing is another form
of digital marketing so you can set up a
marketing campaign so if somebody comes
to your website and does not purchase
the product or service that you're
offering you could take action on that
behavior so I can retarget it's my group
of people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and basically that's the
beauty of digital marketing allows you
to really target users based on their
actions some other uses for digital
marketing and helps build brand
awareness and reputation of your
business so when we say brand awareness
if you're just launching a company and
nobody knows who you are if we use
Google Ads
as our preferred method of digital
marketing and establishing campaigns we
can choose that Display Network that
Display Network on Google Ads reaches a
large amount of people so you can really
get your name out there and really
target your intended audience and allow
that targeted intended audience to
really understand who you are because
they're gonna see your ad in the form of
a banner or in the form of a video or in
the form of text and so that's the
beauty of digital marketing you can
really reach a lot of people and a lot
of people who might be interested in
your product or service and then digital
marketing provides a platform for you to
be interactive with your audience
helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example I can
give here is YouTube and so YouTube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a very sharing platform and so
if I upload a video then I can entice
people to comment on that video or like
the video or share the video and I can
really interact with that audience by
responding to their comments or you know
putting together a playlist or giving
them more videos okay so I can really
interact with my audience and I could do
that on multiple platforms not just
YouTube and video I can blog and
interact based on somebody's comments I
can have a website and have live chat
and interact with my audience so there's
lots of different ways to interact with
an audience and that's what digital
marketing provides so I already
mentioned a few examples based on the
uses of digital more
getting I mentioned Google's Display
Network I mentioned YouTube and blogging
and social media platforms like Facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're gonna start with search
engine optimization it's a search engine
optimization as you probably know from
the name involve search engine and it
involves really making your site
relevant in the eyes of that search
engine so if you're in the United States
you know that Google has a large market
share meaning a lot of people use Google
on a daily basis so we want to make sure
we do everything we can to optimize our
site in order to make our site relevant
for those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people use search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're gonna get and so when we talked
about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of Google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page SEO you have
off page SEO on page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of Google so that's off page SEO so
SEO is always going to be two-prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is dot-com org is relevant in the eyes
of Google and so let's take a look at
on-page SEO
first so like I mentioned it involves
optimizing your website and when we say
optimizing your website there's a lot of
things you
do on your website to make it relevant
in the eyes of Google and we can look at
the content okay and we can look at the
source code and so there are a lot of
different components to be looked at
here so you have the header tag you have
the Meta Description you have the alt
tag you have how fast your page loads
you have internal linking you have a
sitemap you have a lots of different
things going on here and so for me one
of the first things you should do when
you create a page on your website is to
make sure the title tag is unique and
includes those keywords so if we look
here at this example the title tag is
important because that's what shows up
in search results here you can see the
title tag on Google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your URL and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the o rel underneath the
title tag and again this is in search
results so organic searchers will
somebody types in a keyword you want to
be found and you want your title tag to
stick out and you want your meta
description to specifically describe
what it is you're offering ok so again
if somebody's looking for stock imagery
then you want to make sure that you know
that person who's looking for stock
imagery can come to your website and
they can in this case search for
millions of royalty free stock images
photos videos and music and so you want
your description to really get that
person to click on your listing and
organic search that's the whole point so
that's the point of a title tag in a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called site links
and site links are just other or links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
Google so if Google wants to offer up
site links under
your title tag a Meta Description they
will add them and it's based really on
the amount of content you have and that
goes with site search so you can see
also there's Site Search there
underneath the Meta Description all of
that is contingent upon your website do
you have a lot of content and if you
have a lot of relevant content then
Google will naturally add in site links
underneath your organic listing to links
to other pages on your site so that's
on-page SEO and now we're gonna look at
off page SEO okay so off page SEO
involves using promotional methods
beyond just optimizing your site for
example optimizing your title tag a meta
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do some link
building we need to get our name out
there on other web sites okay so we need
to be able to establish some external
links or backlinks from high quality
relevant sites to our site and it may
not just necessarily have to be linked
because Google recognizes
link list backlinks so just having a
reference on a high quality site may be
good enough to get you in the eyes of
Google to become more relevant okay so
that's off page SEO in definition so
really what we want to do is we want to
establish a way to get links from other
websites to our own or references on
other web sites to our website we want
to build those links to help us gain in
ranking so there's lots of ways to do
that
you have social media again you have
social content sites like Reddit medium
Korra you have blogging ok there's lots
of ways to establish yourself out there
on the Internet you just need to make
sure they're quality sites and you need
to make sure they're relevant and so
when you do get a link on an external
site pointing back to yours you want to
make sure it's a follow so you want to
make sure that Google knows to follow
that link from that site to yours so if
you're out there stop
shame content on a third party website
or another website and they're gonna
link back to you just make sure that
it's a follow do follow not a nofollow
okay and I'm going to show you an
example of what that looks like here so
if you're not sure what the difference
is here I'm on backlinko comm and really
a nofollow versus they do follow is
simply in the H wrap so in the H ref if
you don't have anything in there other
than the length in the search engines
are going to follow that link from that
external site to yours and if you have a
nofollow in that link then the search
engines are going to ignore the link so
they're not going to pick up the
backlink or external link to your site
and that's simply that site just adding
the re l equals nofollow okay so if you
see that in the link pointing to your
site from that external site then that
means you're not gonna get credit for
that backlinks so you always want to
shoot for I do follow link because that
means you're gonna get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow search engine crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're gonna get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a nofollow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so it
doesn't pass on the link juice now again
search engines like Google are smart
enough to pick up the association
between a website that talks about your
website and your website so meaning if
you don't have a link and you don't have
a if you have a nofollow link on that
site don't fret because you know Google
has come a long way they're not
necessarily focused on links though it
does help so for example if you are on a
very prominent site and there's no link
then you still may get credit because
Google does recognize linkless backlinks
and that's what they call a linked list
backlink is just having it
prints on that site but you always want
to try and get that follow not they do
not follow okay so here you can see an
example of off page SEO okay like
TripAdvisor would be a good example a
link that redirects from TripAdvisor to
you know The Oprah Magazine as an
example so the Oprah Magazine is going
to get a back link from Trip Advisor to
the site so if Google crawls Trip
Advisor then they're going to be able to
see this link and if it's a follow link
they're gonna give the Oprah Magazine
Matt domain credit from Trip Advisor so
for SEO because there's a two-pronged
approach involved you have on-page and
off-page and a lot of tools here a lot
of tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're gonna look at Google
Keyword planner we're gonna look at Moz
a traps look at some tools that will
help you with both on-page and off-page
SEO so let's start with Google's keyword
planner so why we using Google's keyword
planner because we want to find keywords
okay so we can't do on-page SEO we can't
optimize our title tag and Meta
Description without a good keyword that
we want to be found for so what we want
to do is we want to go into Google Ads
now that's a pay-per-click platform okay
so if you want to be found via paid
search you're gonna use Google ads but
form an organic search perspective we
can use Google's keyword planner so we
need a Google Ads account we have a
Google Ads account then all we need to
do is go to tools then we need to go to
keyword planner and the keyword planner
is a good tool because it allows us to
find those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're gonna do so for example we're
gonna find you know use the keyword mail
delivery if we have a business that
delivers meals to people what keywords
do we want to optimize for so we're
gonna be in Google Ads we're gonna go to
go to tools
we're gonna go to keyword planner we're
going to discover new keywords and we're
simply
just gonna type in a keyword so we're
gonna click get results and Google's
keyword planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was meal delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's twenty two thousand
two hundred search queries on average
over the last twelve months okay so I
can see if I click hover over the graph
here I'm gonna be able to see the
average over twelve months ok so here I
can see the average over twelve months
from July to June 2019 so here what do I
want to do I want to look for trends
because you here I can see the averages
go up and down a little bit but 22,200
is the average over twelve months and
then Google's keyword planner also tells
me how competitive that keyword is so if
it's highly competitive but it's got a
lot of search volume it could be a
keyword I may want to covet but the
beauty of the keyword planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so meal delivery service
it's forty nine thousand five hundred
okay so here you got some other ones
best food delivery service nine thousand
nine hundred again some of these are
very competitive but some of them are
and so you want to be able to do your
due diligence do some analysis and
figure out what keywords work best for
you that aren't going to be competitive
but at the same time give you some
search volume so if you do rank for that
keyword you should expect X amount of
clicks on my keyword based on the volume
so that's Google's keyword planner
alternatively you can use a tool like
Moz com so if I log in to Moz they have
a tool called keyword explorer and so
here I can just type in that same
keyword mail delivery targeting the
United States in English and Moz is
going to give me some information on the
keyword so here they're gonna give me a
range in terms of the monthly volume and
they're going to give me a difficulty
score so
they're gonna tell me how difficult this
keyword is so out of a score of a
hundred it's 53 and they're gonna tell
me what my expected click the rate could
be if I'm ranking for that keyword more
importantly they're going to give me
some other keyword suggestions with just
like Google's keyword planner so here I
can see prepared mail delivery mail
delivery service
mail delivery companies so there are a
lot of different suggestions of keywords
that I can choose from and if we scroll
down we could see basically some
mansions we could see the analysis whose
ranking for these keywords so we can you
really get some insight as to who's
ranking how much volume how difficult it
is what my estimates could be if I'm
ranking etc so a lot of information
built into Moz is keyword Explorer tool
so Moz is keyword Explorer tool could be
a good option for you if you don't have
access to Google Ads
and Google's keyword planner so if
you're working on SEO for a website and
you curious is about what the off page
SEO situation looks like well you can
use a tool like h reps it's a free tool
you can go here if you're working on a
specific domain and you're focused on
off page you can simply type in the
domain here and then you can check the
backlinks for that domain okay so I'm
gonna go ahead and type in my donate my
domain and now I'm gonna get a sense of
what my backlink profile is for my
domain so here I can see the number of
backlinks the total backlinks and notice
85% of them are do follow links so
Google is able to recognize those links
and then I could see referring domains
so I have a hundred and twenty four
different domains pointing to my website
and so here I can get a snapshot of the
top 100 backlinks pointing to my website
and so this just gives me a snapshot of
what's going on with my off page SEO
performance again it's a free tool it's
good to use because it
you an idea of what your off page SEO
situation looks like can another tool
you could use is Pingdom okay you can
set up a free trial here it's good for
14 days and it allows you to you know
look at page speed it allows you to
monitor the site itself in terms of you
know visitors maintenance etc so you can
use Pingdom as well however it's only a
14-day free trial but it does give you
some good insights into SEO now page
load time is one of those on-page SEO
factors and so if you're doing on-page
SEO for domain you certainly want to go
into Google Analytics and you want to
measure the page load performance of the
pages on your website and so here if I
go to Google Analytics and then I go to
behavior and I go to site speed and I go
to speed suggestions here I can see the
pages how many pages I've received over
a period of time and then the average
page load time now if you see the
average page load time is slow and in my
opinion anything over 2 to 3 seconds is
going to be slow you need to be able to
take action and so the great thing about
Google Analytics the page load time
reporting is it actually gives you some
suggestions so PageSpeed suggestions so
all you need to do is click on the link
here in this case this particular link
or URL on my website it has seven
suggestions if I click on that then
PageSpeed insights is going to open up
and what's going to happen is Google
Analytics slash PageSpeed insights is
gonna analyze this page and give me some
feedback on how the page is performing
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well and so here I can see if I analyze
this page I can see some of the
opportunities to improve the page load
time on desktop and again on mobile here
so here you can see a lot of the
opportunities and a lot of the issues
I have that I can address now if you're
going to manage SEO for website then
you're going to need and SEO platform so
again Moz is a good example because we
showed you the keyword Explorer but they
also have many other tools available
built right into the platform for
example rankings okay you can get crawl
information so when the bots crawl the
site what kind of errors are coming up
here and get some page optimisation so I
can choose a keyword and I can choose a
page and Moz is going to be able to give
me feedback to see what more I could do
to improve my on-page SEO performance
okay we mentioned keyword explorer in
terms of looking for keywords okay you
also have something called link Explorer
as well so if I go back then choose link
Explorer from my list here then I'm
gonna go to a link Explorer and I could
type in any domain again just like on
the H wraps except Moz goes a little bit
deeper here okay so they're telling me
how many linking domains and work my
keywords are ranking okay and then I
have some other reports that I can
leverage for off page SEO I can look at
spam scores for certain websites that
are linking to me because you can
disavow yourself from ass being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tools so you can
compare one domain against another to
what links are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different reports
and tools available to you for off page
SEO under Mazdas link explorer so Maas
has a lot of different tools available
and again my recommendation if you don't
use mods there's SCM rush there's bright
edge there's a lot of SEO platforms out
there to use but if you're going to
focus on SEO you are going to need an
SEO platform now if you have any more
questions on SEO you feel free to go to
simply learned YouTube account you'll be
able to find a video there for SEO
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in debt
about everything we just covered about
on-page and off-page SEO so take a look
at the video and if you have any
comments about everything we covered
with SEO feel free to comment underneath
this video here and we'll be sure to
respond accordingly especially if you
have any tips and tricks that you do for
SEO so let's move from search engine
optimization to content marketing and so
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves simulating interest and it
brands products or services by creating
and sharing online material so we talk
about online material that can come in
many forms or assets say some examples
are blogs videos infographics case
studies white papers ebooks all of this
is content generated it's just in
different forms and so you want to be
able to take any one of these forms of
content and be able to distribute that
in some form or fashion okay so for
example a blog can be part of your
website a video could be something you
upload to YouTube an infographic could
be something you actually share on
LinkedIn so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to push
out content so that people have a better
understanding of your product or service
the process of content marketing is you
really want to decide what goal you want
to achieve with your content marketing
campaign you want to define your buyer
personas to determine the audience best
suited for your content okay so what are
you creating who is it for and then you
want to run content on its and determine
the best type of content that can be is
and we talk about content audits we're
talking about you know content that has
already been posted or people sharing it
or people downloading or people viewing
it and so you want to be able to
understand over time what people are
reacting to so that you can
we use or continue to use that content
that seems to resonate with your target
audience so you want to choose an
appropriate content management system so
if it's a blog you want to use WordPress
maybe so you want to start brainstorming
for ideas for new content ideas so my
opinion may be put together a Content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some popular tools used for content
marketing you buffer you've buzzsumo
followerwonk HootSuite so let's go ahead
and take a look at an example of a
content marketing management system and
we're gonna use WordPress and so if we
go into WordPress here on the backend
we're logging a login and so the reason
why we use WordPress is because we can
post blogs so in WordPress if I go to
post here I'm gonna be able to see all
the different posts that have been
posted over a period of time and the
great thing about WordPress is you can
optimize it for SEO so if I go in here
and look at this recent blog post that
has been posted I can go ahead and edit
it and when I edit it okay I'm gonna be
able to look at this blog post in a
visual format and I can also look at it
in HTML form so notice I the great thing
about WordPress is I can use imagery I
can insert videos I can insert
infographics I can attach a white paper
case study to it and then again we have
something called Yoast SEO plugins so
we've a stall the plug-in here so
that'll help us with optimizing that
particular blog post for that particular
keyword we're trying to target and so
here you can see our focus keyword is
remarketing and retargeting okay so we
have that in the title tag okay we also
want to make sure it's in the meta
description and so here we have an
internal link we have it in the
introduction okay we have it you know
spread throughout the content so Yoast
does a good job of allowing us to make
sure we're integrating that keyword into
our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience and in
this case with a blog post we can write
up to you know five hundred to three
thousand keywords and the whole point is
we're trying to introduce our audience
to a particular topic that resonates
with our product or service and so
that's the great thing about blogging
that's the great thing about WordPress
is that you know very easy to use you
can integrate it with SEO
you obviously have commenting you have
different plugins that you can add in
they're very easy to edit and so the why
you can do here with WordPress and
blogging so another example of content
marketing is video so with video you
have the ability to upload this video to
popular video sites like YouTube or
video and you can optimize that
particular video with title tags and and
hashtags and descriptions and you can
see the interaction here so you can see
how many views how many likes shares the
ability to share the ability people for
saving it and there's just a lot of
interactivity when you have video you
can also use video as I mentioned on
your blogging platform if it's WordPress
you can also use video and social media
platforms like Twitter Linkedin and
Facebook so video is a very popular form
of content marketing
lots of good video tools out there to
create a video a high quality video is
what you want to put your profit service
in the best forefront okay so that
people can react they can share they can
comment they could follow they can like
okay so that's what you want to do
is think about video because videos very
versatile and powerful in terms of
getting your message out there so let's
move from content marketing to social
media marketing and social media
marketing really involves creating
content fits that blog if it's that
video that you created for content
marketing and really using different
platforms to increase your visibility
whether that be traffic whether it be
engagement whether it be brand awareness
or any other marketing goals that you
have that's what social media is good
for because social media will take that
content take what you're trying to get
out there and really allow you to hone
your marketing goals against that okay
so if it's Facebook and you got some
videos that you want to post up there ok
what's your goal is your goal to then
post the video to get traffic to your
website or to build brand awareness or
to just get people to react by sharing
or liking and so that's what social
media is good for it's really good for
taking content and really distributing
it to your target audience
ok so sharing content allows you to you
know generate user generated content or
it allows you to create interactive
content and again you can use
infographics or you can apply content
with imagery or post videos or do things
that are interactive like polling and
contests so a lot of flexibility in
terms of the content that you could
share on social media and so you want to
establish a process for social media
marketing so this is the digital
marketing course of it so you want to be
able to have a process and you want to
be able to set up goals that you want to
achieve with your social media campaign
because just posting content for content
sake is really not going to generate
anything for you so you want to set up
those goals ahead of time then you want
to understand what content would be best
suited for your target audience so if
our goal is to generate brand awareness
then
maybe an infographic is what we want to
do okay maybe that's the best choice of
asset for our target audience based on
the platform with social media we also
want to research what the competition is
and find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on Facebook
you can always go to your competitors
website and you can always see you know
what they're posting and what kind of
reaction engagement they're getting for
a particular post so it doesn't help
before you go live to do some due
diligence about your competition you can
also conduct a social media audience
again what we mean by audience just like
on the content side we want to be able
to see what's work and what's not
work in the past and with digital
marketing recall you can get instant
metrics back so if you posted something
last year and you're thinking about
posting it again you probably want to do
an audit to see over the past year what
post of work and have not worked for you
then you want to pick and choose the
social media channels or platforms and
to find a strategy for each of them
because if you have a video then the
video may work on say YouTube we're
Instagram but may not necessarily work
for LinkedIn and Twitter and so you want
to be able to pick and choose the asset
the strategy and align it with the
appropriate platform then you want to
take inspiration from case studies and
other famous brands so can continue to
learn I mean that's the beauty of social
media marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well or
out on social media so take a look at
some of the companies that inspire you
or some other companies in your industry
or even again your competitors and see
what they're doing and what they're
posting and what kind of engagement
they're getting so you should always you
know be able to seek out what others are
doing on social and to me this is
important create a social media content
counter and this isn't necessarily the
very end of the process this goes back
to the beginning of the process
so when you are establishing goals and
you're establishing a type of content
you want to use that should all be part
of a social media content calendar and
I'm going to show you an example of one
here shortly and then again you want to
be able to test evaluate and adjust your
strategy because again you're getting
metrics and if you post a video on
Facebook and it's taking off then
meaning in terms of likes and shares you
probably want to consider maybe doing
another one that complements that so
here's a broad example of a Content
calendar dance in a spreadsheet again by
no means there's one size fits all but
just to give you an idea if we're
blogging what we want to do is we want
to pick our target audience maybe that'd
be country or particular demographic and
you want to come up with some topics
ahead of time here and you want to maybe
put the status up there of you know it's
just a draft or an idea or when it
actually does go live you want to turn
it on live you want to pick your date
add some comments okay
create your content and you know what's
good about a Content counters you can
also work in SEO so you can assign
keywords and then you could add those
keywords to Moz for ranking you can
create your title a Meta Description
then you can carry that content forward
and choose a particular social media
platform to post to so that's the beauty
of a social or excuse me a Content
calendar is allows you to think about
things upfront and then prepare the
content accordingly so you can optimize
it for organic search and post it on
social media for off page SEO and for
social media marketing and so you just
want to get organized ahead of time
using a spreadsheet in this case Google
sheets to lay out the topics ahead of
time so you can write the content for
your intended audience that to me is the
way to go now remember there's lots of
different forms of content that you can
use for social media marketing here we
have video so you can see this video can
be posted on YouTube or LinkedIn or
wherever
the whole point is you want to be able
to measure engagement here you can see
this is just an image it's just a file
and this has been posted on Facebook so
here we could see many likes and
comments and then shares and so you want
to be able to leverage different forms
and different assets across social media
to see actually what works and what
doesn't work and again look at what
other companies have done whether they
be competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there lots tools
available ok your buffer HootSuite
sprinkler post planner later sprout
social I mean the list of social media
marketing tools is endless and just like
SEO you will need a platform to work
with so with F SEO we showed you Moz as
the SEO platform with social we're going
to show you sprout social because with
sprout social if you have a Content
calendar if you have a lot of different
assets you want to be able to organize
those assets and content across multiple
channels and the great thing about using
a social media calendar is yes you can
publish and organize your post
accordingly
you also have most social media platform
tools have listening so you can listen
in on key words and audiences different
brands and industries and conversations
that are being had about a specific
topic and again most social media
platforms if not all have reporting and
so this is important because you can
actually see you know what how your post
or different assets to perform in terms
of engagement and so to me that's
important if you're going to focus on
social media as a platform is as a
channel you want to have a social media
platform tool that will help you
organize your content publish it
accordingly listen in in and get that
report to help you figure out what's
engaging and what's not engaging again
so that you can you
we act to the content that you're using
and sharing
so that's sprout social as an example
but you will need a social media
platform now the other benefit to social
media is in some cases you can actually
pay to have your post out there and so
for example on Facebook we could set up
a paid campaign to target our intended
audience and so with Facebook Facebook
owns Instagram so you have the ability
to really put your content out in front
of your target audience on Facebook and
Instagram and so what you need to do is
go to Facebook Ads manager and simply
just create an account or campaign you
want to be able to create a campaign and
by creating a campaign that means you're
gonna have to go through a particular
process here so if we first we want to
do is choose our objective okay so you
always want to have an objective for
your campaign so is it gonna be brand
awareness is it going to be to drive you
know traffic is it going to be to drive
conversions so you want to choose a goal
or objective if your advertising really
on any platform then you want to be able
to choose your audience so who are we
trying to target so with Facebook you
know you can target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do a single image or video you
can do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile newsfeed Facebook and stream
video you got an Instagram feed you got
even messenger so you have a lot of
options available to you on where your
ad or video is going to be shown and
then you can support that with a
headline description
and you can send that traffic back to
your website you can even test
call-to-action buttons okay so you can
hand your ad with a call-to-action
button and so you can do a lot here this
is just Facebook you can really do a lot
of specific targeting now with Facebook
advertising it's a cost per click model
so anytime somebody does click on that
ad you're going to pay but it allows you
to really get your content out there in
front of your intended audience if
you're not doing it organically meaning
you're not posting on Facebook on a
regular basis or maybe you want to
supplement those organic posts then
doing this is a good way to really get
your brand out there if it's awareness
if it's a drive traffic or to convert
Facebook is a good option LinkedIn
Twitter all these social media platforms
offer that out that option up to do paid
advertising now if you want more
information about social media we have a
great video on YouTube already how to
start social media marketing
it really goes into details about
organic social and what I just covered
with paid social specifically on
Facebook so take a look at that video
and again if I missed anything on the
social media side feel free to comment
we're at in your best practice whether
that be part of the process or a
different platform that you use for
social media okay let's switch to our
next digital marketing channel and
search engine marketing so search engine
marketing is an advertising model that
is good for driving traffic to your site
because you're paying each time someone
clicks on your advertisement now how is
that an equal trade well because you can
advertise on channels like or search
engines like Google or Bing or add row'
which has a big network that includes
Google you can actually pay your way to
the top of search engine rankings and so
if you're at the top for paid search and
somebody touches something like
shoes or something to that effect your
ad can appear at the very top even above
local search even above organic search
and so the visibility is there it's a
good way for you to then get that
traffic that that you you covet for
certain keywords and because you're
getting traffic or other potential to
get traffic you're gonna pay each time
somebody clicks on these ads so you have
multiple choices on the type of asset
you want to use including text image
video etc so there's more to it than
just Google Bing a drawl I mean you have
LinkedIn you have Twitter you have
Facebook sip lots of different ways to
advertise and get your ad in a more
prominent position you just have to pay
for it and I just showed you that under
social media marketing Facebook you can
create an ad have your ad targeting your
audience and in return you're gonna pay
Facebook works the same way for most of
these networks okay so when you actually
set up a campaign like anything you do
when you set up a campaign you want to
determine the goal you want to achieve
for the campaign you want to do that
upfront especially when you're talking
about paying per click if your pay per
click then you definitely want to make
sure you determine what your goals are
so you can measure them accordingly then
you want to choose in this case a
relevant list of keywords you could do
it for your brand meaning you could
choose your own brand keywords you could
choose keywords related to you what your
brand is trying to offer whether that be
a service or product and once you choose
a relevant list of keywords you can
finalize those keywords and then bid on
them so once you start bidding on them
then what you're going to do is align
those keywords with a headline so it's
all done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that I want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you knew
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and lawn
the campaign and start paying Google or
Bing or whomever it is you're
advertising with you want to be able to
measure those goals so that's really the
important part here because regardless
of where you advertise you're going to
be able to monitor campaign results and
so with Google you can even import
conversions into the campaign so for
example if I go to Google ads for
example if I go to tolls ok you can see
I'm running campaigns what am I trying
to accomplish with these campaigns well
in this case and trying to get donations
people click on donations so I can go to
tools click conversions and then I can
see what conversions are added to my
account in that way I can measure my
campaigns against these conversions ok
if I don't see a conversion error I can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case Google Analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns with your
conversions and then just as important
you want to be able to optimize your
campaign because if it's not performing
if you're running a campaign you're
running up cost and you're not getting
conversions you're probably not going to
be continuing to run those campaigns so
you want to optimize your campaign and
retarget potential customers so
retargeting is always a good option
retargeting is targeting someone who
that went to your website and basically
acted in a certain way
meaning they went to a certain page or
abandon the card or actually purchased
or downloaded something ok
you define what action you want that
audience to take in order to retarget to
them ok so the whole point is you can
configure your retargeting campaign
based on certain behavior on your
website and the whole point the ever
target is you're pulling people back to
your website so in addition to
optimizing you know search campaigns you
can one of the benefits of search engine
marketing is you can run retargeting
campaigns so here's an example of an ad
ok so here you can see
it's a good ad in the sense that it's
using everything available to it so for
example here I could see three headlines
so Google in this example allows you to
add in three headlines so here you can
see simply learn official site get
certified get ahead then you can see
simply learn calm so they're taking
advantage of three headlines and then
here you can see two description lines
and so each description line you can
have up to 90 characters and so you want
to be able to take advantage of what
Google gives you the more information
you can add the better well here you can
see some other types of ads here you can
see a banner ad for slack okay here you
can see betterment com running in a
minute okay so this looks like an ad
that was on YouTube so because you can
see after a few seconds you can skip the
ad okay see here's a video ad here's an
image ad and here's a text ad so
depending on what platform you advertise
on you have an an option on what type of
asset you want to use you know the one
thing I like about Facebook is they
offer a multitude of options in terms of
assets so you can run a single image ad
you can run a carousel meeting kind of
multiple images you can run a video you
can run a combination video image you
would obviously run text okay with a
thumbnail so you have a lot of options
in terms of the type of ad you can run
so before we move into our next channel
let me just show you an example of you
know how an ad actually looks on a
particular website so here you can see
I'm on BuzzFeed news calm okay here you
can see Volkswagen Golf is running an
advertisement in Spanish on this
particular site so they're either using
Google or some other platform and having
that platform if it's Google post their
ad on this particular site so here you
can see it's a banner ad and if we're in
Google ads and you're setting up a text
ad let me just run through you what the
text at it looks like remember you want
to always take advantage of what's
offered to you because especially text
ads you have very few care
and with very few characters it's hard
to get your message across so with
Google you have your final URL which is
where people are going to go to after
they click on your ad but you have one
not one not two but three headlines that
you can take advantage of so we're
talking about help end child hunger help
today you know you can always add in
visit our website for more info I mean
you want to take advantage of what's
available to you now again here you can
see in this example I'm only allotted 30
characters and it's if you go over then
your ads not going to get approved so
you really have to be cognizant of the
character counts and getting your point
across because writing text ads is not
the easiest thing to do when you're
limited to characters now with Google
you have what they call a display path
so after the domain you can add in a
couple of keywords in there and then you
have description line one and
description line two so again take
advantage of what's available if you're
not sure what copied or I grabbed some
from the website and paste it in there
you want your ads to be healthy and to
have as much information as possible and
then the one thing I will say about
Google ads is they also have extensions
so extensions are exactly that they're
extensions to your text ads so here you
can see I have four extension these are
actually site links so Google ads offers
up something called ad extension so it
could be call-outs site links can be
location extensions app extension so
they have a number of different
extensions that they can append to your
ad so take advantage of that as well
remember the whole point of ads is to
make a compelling case for your product
or service so that somebody can click on
the ad and go to your website and then
perform the action you want them to
perform now if you have any more
questions about Google ads feel free to
check out our in-depth video about
Google ads it covers everything a-to-z
on Google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn YouTube
playlist for Facebook Twitter
social media marketing so if you're
curious to know a little bit more about
search engine marketing you know check
out any one of these videos that we have
listed on our YouTube channel ok so
let's move over to affiliate marketing
now
and so with affiliate marketing really
it's interesting and unique and that
affiliate marketing involves paying out
commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service ok these people
who are selling your product or service
on your behalf are gonna get
commissioned or incentivize based on
whatever action you put out there so it
could be registrations just getting your
affiliates to help you with just getting
people registered or signing up for your
email or you for a lot of you
conversions you're trying to sell a
product so you want help in selling that
product or it could be subscriptions ok
signing up to something ok so you
determine what it is you want to
incentivize your affiliates for you also
determine how much you're going to
incentivize them and that's the great
thing about affiliate marketing it's
it's no different than having a sales
team to support you what are the steps
for affiliate marketing well you need to
find a platform there are lots of
different affiliate platforms out there
you know Commission Junction or CJ comm
comes to mind because these platforms
are going to help you find these
affiliates or partners ok so they're the
broker and all this and so when you set
up your platform you're going to
establish rules guidelines post images
and banners and assets for those
affiliates to use on their websites
and more importantly again you're going
to establish the Commission so the
Commission doesn't have to be the same
for all affiliates it could simply be
you know your top affiliates get a
higher Commission
as opposed to just some other affiliates
who get a starting Commission you
establish everything on the platform the
affiliate platform that you choose now
affiliates apply to advertise on your
behalf so they're gonna say hey I'm
interested in selling your product or
service so you're gonna use that
platform if it's Commission Junction to
approve or disapprove the rikka filius
request to advertise on your behalf and
really what you want to try and do is
leverage the platform as best as you can
a lot of these affiliates are out to
make money and some of them are really
good you need to be able to choose the
affiliate that is going to represent
your brand product or service the best
so it's simple customer clicks on an ad
or link okay on that affiliate website
and they go to your website and they
perform an action so that could be a
purchase or registration a subscription
a download an email signup you determine
that and the great thing is these
affiliate networks the CJS commission
Junction's of the world will record
everything they're tracking not only
traffic from the affiliate website to
your website but they're also tracking
the conversions the transaction is
validated and credited to the affiliate
by the broker and then the affiliate has
paid his or her commission so that's how
it works so the more the affiliate cells
or converts on your behalf the more
they're going to make and that's the
beauty of the affiliate network so
here's an example of affiliate marketing
okay here you can see an advertisement
here okay so you can see profit from our
experience earning up to 12% advertising
fees with a trusted e-commerce list
leader so somebody clicks on that link
joins and then this person is going to
get a commission based on somebody
joining for free again I mentioned
Commission Junction they are also some
other affiliate marketing tools out
there Matt Amazon Associates a win trade
double or max
there's there's a lot out there CJ comm
is the one I've used in the past but you
know give some of these other platforms
a chance okay it doesn't hurt to even be
on multiple platforms you have nothing
to lose okay when you're on a platform
basically the platform again is acting
as the mental person they're introducing
you to affiliates and so every time you
actually pay an affiliate a commission
they're gonna get their cut of it so
they're gonna get a small percentage as
well so just keep that in mind but you
know give it a try try one or two of
these affiliates if you find you're
getting quality affiliates that are
selling your product or service great if
you don't then you know feel free to
change you know affiliate networks it's
that simple but the key here is find the
affiliates you think are gonna best
represent your brand product or service
because those affiliates are likely
gonna be the ones to convert for you and
if your small business starting out and
you need somehow affiliate marketing is
the way to go okay let's move over to
native advertising
okay so native advertising so maybe our
advertisement means that your ad is
showing up next to content that
basically naturally fits so these are
advertisers that are featured on a
platform alongside the content okay that
isn't paid for okay so for example here
you can see a paid post okay this is by
Spotify okay this paid post okay was on
BuzzFeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about you
bands that probably wouldn't exist
without Led Zeppelin okay so for Spotify
you using native advertising allows them
to put their ad next to content related
to their ad here you can see another
BuzzFeed article okay 11 great Amazon
deals that will be music to your ears if
your audio file here you can see an
advertisement next to the article so you
can see the ad about Led Zeppelin and
here you can see the actual article is
about music so the whole point about
native advertising is making sure
there's a can
action between the and the article so
modify is advertising okay their product
and service on an article on BuzzFeed
which happens to be about music so a
good example we use BuzzFeed just a
second ago so if we go to BuzzFeed here
you can see I'm in TV and movies and
here you can see got an ad here if we
scroll down keep scrolling down we can
see another ad here for HBO and so this
ad makes sense because it's placed on
TVs and movies so people who go and read
the contents are gonna see an ad related
to that content so that's generally what
native advertising is you need to be
able to be able to place the ad on the
right pages okay so you're gonna need an
ad network for that so we talked about
paid search advertising we talked about
Google Ads so Google Ads has the ability
to place your ad natively on particular
pages that are relevant to that ad so
that's really what native advertising is
all about making sure that your ad is
placed next to content that's naturally
relevant so if you need more information
about affiliate marketing feel free to
visit simply learns YouTube channel we
have a nice in-depth video about
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platform's how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing spread around
the longest it's kind of the grandfather
of all digital marketing channels so
email marketing really is used to
personalise emails in order to convert
that recipient or that perspective user
into a customer and so like all the
other digital marketing channels we want
to follow some type of flow a process or
methodology and the first step in email
marketing is you have to identify your
target audience okay when you identify
your target audience you're gonna create
a segment okay so in other words you
don't want to send one email
to everyone because not everyone is
going to be interested in that email so
in order to get somebody interested you
need to be able to send an email
tailored to that audience okay so that
audience can respond and react
accordingly so once you target that
audience and create segments email
segments you're gonna create the
campaign and set up an appropriate call
to action one note of care is when you
create the campaign and set up that
appropriate call to action that call to
action is gonna be aligned with your
goal so what is the goal of the email
campaign is it simply to get people to
click on something a purchase or is it
simply to get people to click on
something and sign up or watch something
or cement some information or download
or whatever the case you need to
establish that up front just like you
would with a search engine marketing
campaign or any other type of campaign
you want to run so there are lots of
tools out there just like with affiliate
marketing you want to choose an
appropriate email marketing tool
there are plenty to be had each work in
a very similar nature some offer
different pricing models meaning you
know you can send an email to X
recipients for flat fee or you pay a
small amount per email address each one
is slightly different in terms of how
they price but in terms of the features
they all work in a very similar fashion
and we're going to show you an example
of one here shortly so when you choose
that email marketing tool you're gonna
test your emails before you send them
out and then when you test your emails
you're gonna use that email marketing
tool that actually send the campaign
after it's been tested ok so you want to
send the campaign you can immediately
send them out or you can schedule them
now a best practice with an email is
when you actually send one out you're
sending an email out to your target
audience
you want to create probably two emails
per segment audience why because you
want to add an attractive subject line
and copy to the email but if
sent two emails to the same target
audience then you want to test the
subject lines you want to be able to see
what subject line is going to entice
somebody to open the email okay that's
the beauty of email marketing is you can
do that okay so you can set up your
design based on your target audience but
it's always these subject line that
people see first so you want to write an
attractive subject line and copy that's
going to entice somebody to open the
email so why not send two emails to each
target audience that way you can see
what email subject line works best so
that's the whole idea of about
performing a be test to test out
different ideas it doesn't necessarily
have to be a subject line it could be
the same subject line two emails but the
difference being the body of the email
it's totally up to you but the idea here
is to always split out your emails per
target audience and just like any other
channel whether it be affiliate or
search engine marketing organic search
you want to analyze performance and in
the case of emails it's always about
open rates how many people are opening
then how many people are clicking and
then how many people are actually
responding are they converting or
downloading or whatever it is you want
them to do you need to be able to
monitor the behavior because for example
if your open rates don't work or they're
low then you know something's wrong with
your subject line so you want to be able
to make an adjustment so here's an
example of an email from Airbnb it's a
simple email okay they're just simply
trying to get somebody to click on that
call to action to take the survey okay
that's really all it's about here with
this particular email so who is their
target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at a Airbnb property or it could
be somebody who used the app probably
Airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the
survey so they're probably measuring and
we people open it how many people
clicked on the CTA the call to action
and then how many people are actually
filled out the survey so you need to
follow each step and track each step
accordingly
okay so again some popular tools used in
email marketing let's take a look at
MailChimp here but I will mention like
Marketo is a good marketing automation
tool now owned by Adobe Marketo allows
you to send those drip campaigns so if
somebody doesn't purchase right away you
can send up follow-up emails like say
one day out or seven days out or
fourteen days out so HubSpot works in a
very similar fashion you want to be able
to methodically plan out your emails
that's the point I'm trying to make here
so let's take a look at MailChimp so if
we go over into MailChimp a very easy
interface okay here we go under audience
we can actually see who our audience is
we can break out our audience into
different groups you can have a simple
test list you can have people who
purchase people who subscribe to
something okay so you can break out your
audience into different groups okay when
it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of MailChimp we can actually
see what campaigns have been dropped or
sent out array and then we could see the
opens the clicks and then the
conversions so MailChimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure that reports or how well the
campaign performs so here we can see
specifically how many people open
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounce and how many people
unsubscribe from the list and here we
can see you know the top links that have
been clicked okay the subscribers with
the most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here
right in MailChimp and you want to be
able to react to the emails you send out
so if an email is not performing okay
you want to learn from that see you
don't make the same mistake again great
thing I like about MailChimp too they
have a lot of nice templates to use so
if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage
so that's milchem kind of in a nutshell
MailChimp
you could pay up front buy credits and
with those credits you could send out
emails to a number of people okay so
that's how MailChimp works they do have
a free trial so you can set up an
account using the free trial now if you
need any more information about
MailChimp or email marketing in general
take a look at the email marketing
webinar we have set up on or simply
learn YouTube account now let's finish
up with online PR or press releases so
we talked about SEO and social and
search and affiliate and email marketing
and content native advertising let's
talk about online PR here because with
online PR it really does involve working
with digital publications or blogs or
other content related websites for
example content related websites could
be newspaper digital newspaper sites
like the New York Times okay the whole
point of you online PR is you want to
try and get some publicity on those on
those web sites publicity means
awareness for the brand it means traffic
to the web site and eventually some
loyalty future customers and immersion
channels that can be used to maximize
your online PR efforts for example you
connect with reporters on social media
to develop a relationship so you can
just follow some reporters see if
they're covering specific industries or
verticals and if they are similar to
what you're offering then it's probably
a good idea to reach out to them you can
use engaging user reviews to help
humanize your brand or you can respond
to comments that help generate
productive conversations so those are
all certain things you can do to
generate
where 'no send buzz for your brand so
really the one point thing I want to
point out online PR is basically you can
also hire a PR firm and they can do some
of the heavy lifting for you or like I
said you can reach out to different
reporters or different influencers even
to help push your product or brand now
if you're trying to go at it alone on
the online PR what you could do if you
don't reach out to reporters or
influencers or your active in trying to
build your brand through conversation
you can always use a third-party service
like PR comm so PR comm allows you to
you know basically create your own
profile you know submit content to your
own profile or even submit press
releases
if you submit press releases then other
news agencies are gonna pick up on those
press releases so it's a good way to get
your press releases out there likes of
Yahoo and google might pick up those
press releases and give you some you
know much-needed visibility you can also
use other tools like you know PR
Newswire for example so it works in a
very similar way again it's a press
release distribution network so you can
go ahead and sign up for an account get
that press release out there and they do
the distribution for you or you can also
use aggregation site so there are lots
of different aggregate sites out there
and so what aggregate web sites do is
they help disseminate and distribute
your content so here you can see some of
the new aggregator websites at 2019 you
got a feedly panda techne me Metacritic
East science news the morning news so
you have a lot of options available to
get your content out there okay so what
these sites do is basically pick up
articles that fit their website fit
their theme fit their target audience so
you do have options in the form of
third-party tools as well okay so
if you don't hire a PR firm which could
be expensive you can certainly go at it
alone by signing up for any one of these
particular products or services okay so
well that'll do it for today's webinar I
want to thank you for hanging in there
going over all these digital marketing
channels with me if you have any
comments on any of them feel free to add
a comment below this video otherwise if
you need more information please visit
simply learn comm thank you again and
I'll see you soon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here